but don't you think
maybe i don't know who the right example
is whether it's stalin i think hitler
might be the better example of
don't you think or jeffrey epstein
perhaps
don't you think people who are evil will
will find ways to manipulate human
nature
to attain power no matter the system yes
and like the the corollary question is
do you think those people can get more
power
in um in the democracy in a you know
in when there's a government already in
place they can it's easily they get more
power more dangerous to have a
government place
first of all sociopaths for their charm
and for their
warmth here's the two situations
in in a free society i'm a sociopath i'm
an evil person
i'm the head of macy's in a state
society i'm an evil person i'm a
sociopath i'm the head of the us
government
which of these are you more concerned
with it's like night and day
so you would have far more decentralized
military you would have far more
decentralized um
uh uh security forces and they would be
much more subject to feedback from the
market
if you have an issue with macy's or any
store with a sweater
look at that transaction if you have an
issue with the state
to you hiring a lawyer costs more than a
surgeon to even access
the mechanism for dispute is going to be
exorbitant and price poor people out of
the market for um
conflict resolution immediately so right
away you have something that's extremely
regressive
and even though this is touted as some
great equalizer it's quite the opposite
so in current society there's deep
suspicion of governments and states
they're not that's not really like just
your example of macy's i mean
don't you think a hitler could rise to
be at the top
of a social network like twitter and
facebook okay let's suppose hitler ran
twitter
okay let's take this thought experiment
seriously
literally what could he do so all the
only tweets are gonna be about how much
the jews suck
right okay fine okay all the cool people
are leaving
there could be some compelling like you
said
um evil people are charming there could
be some compelling narratives that could
be with conspiracy theories
uh untruths that could be spread like
propaganda
every criticism of anarchism is in fact
a description
all the strongest criticisms of
anarchism are in fact description of the
status quo
your concern is under anarchism
propaganda would spread and people would
be taught the wrong ideas unlike the
status quo
that's not even a criticism of anarchism
i'm not actually criticizing
it's an open question of
it's an open question of in which system
will
human nature thrive be
be able to thrive more and in in which
system would the evils
that arise in human nature would be more
easily suppressable
there that's that's the opportunity it's
a scientific experiment
and i'm asking only from a perspective
of the fact that
we've tried democracy quite a bit
recently
and we i don't maybe you can correct me
we haven't yet
seriously tried anarchy in a large scale
well we don't need to try to
so anarchy isn't like a country right
it's like it's you can't
i'm not it's like saying well if anarchy
works how come we've never had an
anarchist government right
so anarchism is a relationship and
language is an example of this it's a
worldwide
and our system you and i have an
anarchist relationship there's almost no
circumstances we'd be calling the police
on each other i mean it's i'm asking the
same question
in a bunch of different directions out
of born out of my curiosity is
why is anarchy going to be
better at preventing the darker sides of
human nature which
presumably your criticism of government
because it's because of decentralization
so the darker side of human nature is an
extreme concern
anyone who says it's going to go away is
absurd
and fallacious i think that's a
non-starter when people say that
everyone's going to be good human beings
are basically animals we're capable of
great
beauty and kindness we're capable of
just complete
cruel and what we would call inhumanity
but we see it on a daily basis even
today
uh and what's interesting is the
corporate press
won't even tell you the darkest aspects
because that's too upsetting to people
so they'll tell you about atrocities and
horrors but only to a point
um and then when you actually do the
homework you're like oh it's so much
worse than
like that thing about stalin right so we
know in a broad
sense that stalin was a dictator we know
that he killed a lot of people but it
takes work
to learn about the holodomor it takes
work to learn about what those
literal tortures were and that this is
the person who later
fdr and harry truman were shaking hands
with and taking photos with and was
being sold to us as uncle joe
you know he's just like you and me um so
when you have a decentralized
information
network as opposed to having three media
networks
it is a lot easier for information that
doesn't fit what would be the corporate
american narrative
to reach uh the the populations and it
would be more effective
for democracy because they're in a much
better position to be informed now
you're right it also means well if
everyone has a mic that means
every crazy person and with their wacky
views and at a certain point yeah it has
to become
then there's another level which is then
the people have to be self-enforcing
and and you see that on social media all
the time where someone says this the
other person jumps in
you think but isn't social media a good
example of this like
so you think ultimately without
centralized control
you can have stability like
what about the mob outrage and the mob
rule the
the power of the mobs that that emerge
power of the mob
is is a very uh serious concern uh
gustav labon wrote a book in the 1890s
called the crowd
and this was one of the most important
books i've written because it influenced
both mussolini and hitler and stalin and
they all talked about it
and he made the point that under crowd
psychology
human lynching is another example of
this none of those individuals or very
few
would ever dream of doing these acts but
when they're all together
and you lose that sense of self you
become the ant and you lose that sense
of individually
you're capable of doing things that like
in another context you'd be like
i should kill myself i'm a monster so
you're worried about that but
like is in the mob doesn't the mob have
more power under anarchy
no the mob has much less power on
anarchy because under anarchism every
individual
is fully empowered you wouldn't have uh
um
gun restrictions you would have people
creating communities based on shared
values
they would be much more collegial they'd
be much more kind
as opposed to when you're forcing people
to be together in a polity
when they don't have things in common
that is again like having a bad roommate
if you're forced to look at jails if
you're forced to be
in locked in a room with someone even if
you at first like them
after a while you're going to start to
hate them and that leads to
very nefarious consequences
you